redondo empty beaches are a sign of the
times in Southern California as most
residents follow a statewide
stay-at-home order
more than half of the 50 US states are
now under those orders intended to slow
the spread of coronavirus the federal
government extended until April 30th its
guidance that people maintain social
distancing with a number of confirmed
cases and deaths rising one of the
country's top infectious disease experts
says the final toll could be very high
looking at what we're seeing now you
know I would say between 100 and 200
thousand cases but I don't want to be
held to that because it's it's it's
excuse me deaths I mean we're gonna have
millions of cases but I just don't think
that we really need to make a projection
when it's such a moving target
governor's like New York's Andrew Cuomo
painted a sobering picture I don't see
how you get past that curve without
seeing thousands of people pass away
Louisiana is already running short on
hospital space we're on a trajectory
currently to exceed our capacity in the
New Orleans area for ventilators by
about April the 4th and all beds
available in hospitals by about April
the 10th Michigan's Detroit Auto Show is
canceled and the convention center where
it's usually held will be converted to a
field hospital we see this astronomical
rise we've got hospitals that are
already at capacity
Illinois's governor said he desperately
needs more testing kits the White House
has promised millions of tests for weeks
now and they're just not here in a
briefing President Donald Trump made the
shocking and unsubstantiated claim that
the shortage of masks and other
protective equipment and hospitals may
be because nurses and hospital staff are
stealing them
they've been delivering for years 10 to
20 thousand masks ok it's a New York
Hospital very it's packed all the time
how do you go from 10 to 20 to 300,000
10 to 20,000 masks to 300,000 even
though this is different
something's going on and you ought to
look into it as reporters wear the
masculine are they going out the back
door I don't think it's hoarding I think
it's maybe worse than hoarding earlier
Trump tweeted with evident pride that
his daily briefings were getting great
television ratings higher than some
popular reality shows Rob Reynolds
al-jazeera